Okay.
Hey, what's going on? It's Bill Burn and
It's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday, Monday
morning podcast and ahhh
just checking in on you. Just checking
in on you, seeing how your week's going.
How's your week going on?
Did you have fucking team?
Have another championship parade
like minded. Well, you know what?
I wish it did. Why the fuck should
my town have all the Goddamn success?
You know, it's fucking unbelievable.
I still can't believe you won that
fucking game, but I'm not going to go
on and on and on and on and on
and on and on and on and on and on
about it. Um, I'm in Charlotte,
North Carolina came in a day
before the comedy zone Gig.
I went to the a shallot hornets
versus the Brooklyn Nets,
you know, and when you try to go to
a home game, sorry, I'm going to, um,
I don't have my fucking microphone,
so I'm just recording. Right.
If my laptops are, anytime I click on
something, it might be God damn issue. Um,
but, uh, when you're trying to do
what it is that I've been doing,
which is to basically
go to all of the, uh,
to go to a home game of every fucking
team and all four major sports,
every once in a while you got to go
to a game. It's not the best game.
You've got to go see a couple of
franchises that even though they,
they've had their moments, this
is not their time. They are,
they're currently re
rebuilding. And that's what,
that's what happened when we saw the
Charlotte Hornets play the Brooklyn Nets.
Um, a couple nights ago,
Jesus Christ, it was,
it was just like it was, I don't
know. I don't know what it wants.
It was like a fucking WWE NBA game.
WNB A at its worst in the first
couple of seasons, you know, they,
they just didn't look good. I
mean, they look way better now,
the fundamentals and all that,
if he's watch any of the WNB.
But those first few years,
I couldn't understand why it looks so
bad cause women's college basketball look
better in a w NBA. But Jesus
Christ Charlotte Verse Brooklyn,
Geesh, that I say that enough time, oh
this is how fucking boring that game was.
The kids that played at halftime was
fucking more exciting cause they will run
in the court. Big smiles on their
faces was fucking hilarious.
That game was like something
like, you know, 16 to 14.
And it was all layups. It was
just all fucking run in the court.
Layups was tremendous. And um,
yeah.
But anyways, last night,
uh, we went to um, yeah,
we worked the comedy zone and uh, I did,
the smartest thing I've ever done on the
road in a long time was when the show
was over. I just went home
and I went to fucking bed. Um,
because the Charlotte
Brooklyn night, you know,
I had a couple of pops about 17, and
uh, the next day woke up. I'm like,
what the, what am I doing?
What, what the fuck am I doing?
Okay, I've got a newborn at home.
I can't get any goddamn sleep.
I'm on the road now. I should be like,
like a fucking sober as a church
mouse and just go right to bed.
And that's what I did last
night. Fucking phenomenal.
Other than God damn fucking cleaning
ladies coming by every 10 minutes.
Yeah, they didn't, they,
this place I'm staying in doesn't
have the fuck off side. Um,
so they just keep coming.
Housekeeping 11, they fucking knock,
right housekeeping and then immediately
open the Goddamn door. There's that.
There's the lost art
of knocking on a door,
waiting for a response and then
coming in somewhere along the line.
These goddamned kids today. Oh yeah,
I just said that these goddamn kids,
they think the fact they just knocked
that they can just means they can then
enter the room. You knock, you
wait for somebody to say, you know,
hang on a second, or blah
blah, blah, blah, blah.
You don't just knock on a
fucking door and walk in.
You've got to give the
person a chance, you know,
put the dick away or something, you
know? Well, who knows what they're doing.
Maybe they're just sitting
there in their underwear, right?
I don't fucking know. She fucking
knock and you wait and then you went,
sorry, just saying it fucking can't stand.
That's one of my pet peeves annoys people
who knock and then they just fucking
walking, um, that shit. Or if you know,
when you go into to a parking spot,
you know with two cars could fit and you
just stick your fucking cunt car right
in the middle of both. So no one can fit.
Two cars can fit anymore unless
you drive in a smart car. Um,
so anyways, tonight you probably
think Jesus bill have to uh,
that patriots Superbowl.
How could your sport,
okay,
I could just sportsworld
get any better. You don't,
I mean we'll after a major
dip I believe on Monday,
which I think they did on purpose cause
the Bruins had a little gap in their
schedule with all the buzz about
do we give the patriots excuse,
we have yard care
be a good time to get rid
of a Clo Julian and a,
I just want to thank
coach Juliette for, uh,
being the best Bruins coach since
I've been watching them. Um,
for the last, you know,
close to 40 years. Um,
Jesus [inaudible] everybody adversely,
I'm doing my podcast.
Okay.
All right. Let me, let me in
an hour. You think or no? Uh,
there's just the Thursday one. I'll be
done in like a half hour. All right,
cool. And then if you
want to talk, Hey Paul,
you go eat those eggs and then
I'll meet you first steam.
Okay.
All right. We got breakfast coming in
like 20, and when it's done I'll call you.
Okay. All right buddy. Okay,
pal. Okay. Alright, cutie.
Anyways, um,
the fuck don't fuck was I talking
about? Um, yeah. Hello Julian.
Jesus Christ. I'd never seen a guy
more of a victim of the GM and for the,
I do not that fucking move whatsoever.
You know, I guess maybe if he had
fallen out with the people up top,
I have no idea. But, um,
how you just gonna blame it on him
and not get rid of your fucking GM.
I don't know what they see in this.
Our GM, I have no fucking idea.
I don't know. Um,
okay.
I have no idea what this
guy is doing. I mean,
he got rid of everybody and I just
didn't, I don't see that way. We actually,
we're playing our best hockey of the
year. I felt, yeah, we won three in a row.
Lost a tough one of the fucking
capital's not a tough one.
They actually kicked our ass five to two.
But I mean what the fuck did the capitals,
we didn't do bad for a seventh seed.
I don't know. I think it's a dumb move.
You get rid of the guys like okay,
you want to get rid of the guy? Who
are you gonna replace them with?
WHO's out there, you know,
and actually tweeted
congratulations to every year,
every other NHL team out there that needs
a fucking coach that knows how to win
a cup. Um, cause that's
what we just dumped.
Um, I dunno,
I dunno.
I don't know to get the shit that stuff
where the ownership gives into the fan
base. It's like, what
are they listening to?
The fucking dopes that call
into sports talk radio.
I've never called in a sports talk.
I'd watch sports all the fucking time.
I would never call it a sports
talk radio show, you know,
just specifically to talk
about the sports thing. I mean,
I'll call in and the hyper show,
you know, who wore myself out. Oh,
I would absolutely do that. Oh,
speaking of worn myself out.
Um, well wait, wait, wait, wait. Let
me get back. So, uh, thank you Clo,
Julian and uh, for bringing us
the Stanley Cup and uh, and in a,
you know, 40 year drought, um,
and continued success wherever you go.
I know you're gonna do
great wherever you go.
Hopefully you've got a better GM
at the next place you go to. Um,
so anyways, um,
after all my ranting and
raving about, uh, award shows,
I think I might be a presenter at one
old Hollywood bill is
the writers guild awards.
And um, they asked me to be a presenter
or whatever. And at first I was like,
then I'm not going to go down and
do that fucking bullshit. But then,
you know what, I'm actually,
I guess often enough or selling
out, depends on how you look at it.
But what I realize is that on our show,
um, it's those awards shows
are a big deal for, uh,
for the writers because that's
how they actually get money.
So if you win an an Emmy, um,
or a writers guild or a
sag thing or whatever,
it's great for the writers in the
writers room cause they can say that they
wrote on an Emmy award winning show
and Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
So old freckles has to play
the game a little bit. Um,
go put it on a God damn monkey suit to
fucking black tie thing. I got to go,
I'm going to go to one of those fucking
from places where they have the cheap
tuxedos cause I don't think
anybody can fucking tell,
just come out in those God
damn plastic bowling shoes. Um,
I don't know who the fuck decided that
they wanted me to be a fucking presenter,
but like, if they've never,
they've obviously never listened
to me read out loud on a,
on my podcast. But, uh, I don't know.
I figured this would be a good one to
try out to see what I think about it
because a, it's not televised, you know?
And um,
I don't know if we'll see if
I can actually read out loud.
I don't know if knee has been on me
about this shit. You gotta do it.
You gotta play the game. Alright,
I'm playing the bucket game.
Why make a fucking difficult business
even more? God damn difficult.
I'm like fuck it. I'll give it a two.
I'll let you guys know how that goes.
How my reading out loud, if that's
in fact what they have. Me Too.
But it's not bad. It's only
like two hours long. Um,
so it Kinda seems like the best one to
go to and Patton Oswald is hosting it and
I think he's a fucking genius, so at
least I'll get to listen to his monologue.
Um, but I am without a doubt.
I am going to get the fuck.
I'm going to get a nice fucking, I'm
going to get a senior prom special,
the clip on fucking tie
and all of that shit.
That's like the dumbest shit ever to go
out and go buy some expensive Tuxedo.
It's like, what are you a
fucking Rockefeller? Uh,
but I guess people trash you then,
right when you watch walk the red
carpet or something like that. Um,
so anyways, so there you go.
This my fully shit moment I have to make
in front of all those fucking awards
shows. Uh, I'm actually
gonna walk, go to one.
I don't know. What are you going to
do the fuck am I going to do right?
I'm doing it for the tape. Okay.
Can I get out of it by saying that?
So anyways, I was saying,
um, how my, um, my,
uh, my sporting world, how it
could get any better after the, uh,
the Patriots win and then the, uh, the,
the let down of seeing them given to the
fan pressure or whatever the fuck they
did. Getting rid of coach
Julian, um, tonight,
me for Z and a Joe Barnick or doing a
bucket list thing for any person that's
even remotely into sports.
We're going to the, uh,
the Duke versus a North
Carolina Tarheels game tonight.
And we've got some great seats,
was sitting right behind the f the
fucking Duke Bench coach k's going to be
there. If it wasn't so God damn loud in
that place, we could hear him, you know,
during the timeouts and everything,
it's going to be crazy. So, uh,
I don't know. It was a chance
you might see the three,
three of us dummies on TV. Um,
okay.
But beyond excited to go to this like
this is, there's a fucking huge one.
This is a huge one. Um, as far as the
bucket list, sports stuff to go to, uh,
years ago I told you, I don't know
if I told you guys I went to the, um,
I went to uh,
okay.
Indiana university
versus, um, what was it?
Michigan state and I believe it was a
year that Michigan State won the National
Championship and Bobby Knight
was still coaching there. And um,
okay.
I've never seen anything like that.
All the years, everything I've ever,
every sporting event I've ever gone to,
I have never seen anything like
watching Bobby Knight coach a game.
I mean that guy, you watched
him more than as much,
if not more than you
were watching the game.
I was actually rooting for
the Spartans. You know,
I came there rooting for Indiana, but
Bobby was so fucking entertaining.
I started rooting for the Spartans
because I wanted to see him flip out even
more. I've never seen somebody with, yeah,
she made me feel good about myself.
Like just complete loss of composure
obviously or whatever his
coaching style motivating people.
I remember they let up a couple
of easy buckets in this kid.
The point guard starts bringing it up the
court and Bobby Knight is like 10 feet
onto the court and he's
yelling so much. He's like,
do you have a c a was it Ben Kingsley
and sexy bass? When he, when he's,
when he's yelling and being
a right content and he's
like throwing his head into
everything that he's saying.
That's what the fuck he was doing.
But it was way more intense cause
he wasn't acting. He was serious.
And um, I've never fucking
seen anything like that.
And that's one of my favorite of
everything that I've seen in sports.
The coolest thing ever is that I got
to see Bobby Knight Coach at Indiana
University.
Matt's fucking legendary like scenes
Zeplin we're seeing the Beatles, you know,
James Brown or whatever, like,
you know, that's right up there.
I saw Eddie Murphy on the
raw tour. I saw Eddie Wee.
These might think
greatest things I've seen.
I've seen Eddie Murphy on the raw tour.
I said when he went the purple suit,
I saw Bobby Knight, coach Indiana.
Um,
okay,
the fuck did I go from there? So
Judas Priest and the Turbo Lover Tour,
does that count?
I know I saw Stevie Ray Vaughn.
Um,
I saw Dan Marino kicked the
shit out of the Patriots,
um,
with Don Shula coaching
as someone. Great. Yeah.
Thinking about being an old guy as you
can start talking about all this shit
since like, nope, that now fucking no
longer exists. So I actually made a,
a few guys who just bear
with me clicking here, sorry.
And let's fucking loud as hell.
I know it's annoying and you're going
to listen to it again. Right now.
All right. I actually looked through, um,
okay.
I got this, this document teams scene
and um,
okay.
I have seen 31.
Okay.
I've been to a home game if
every major league baseball team,
I haven't been to all the stadiums
cause like the mets changed.
There's got a new one.
Philly's got a new one. Um,
but I've seen a total of 31.
There's 30 professional baseball teams.
I've seen 31 cause I went to the expos.
Um, I've seen 32 home games
of the NFL. There's 32 teams,
but I still need to see the
Tampa Bay Buccaneers there.
The last one I need to see, but I
saw the St Louis and the fucking, um,
the Saint Louis and the
fucking, uh, La Ramps.
So that's how I got up to
32. I've seen 25 NBA teams.
Uh, one of those being the a,
I saw both the Seattle Sonics.
Okay.
And the, uh, Oklahoma City Thunder.
Um,
and I saw the New Jersey Nets and I got
to go see the fucking Brooklyn that's
speaking of which I also
saw the fucking, oh,
did I see the fucking the islanders at
Nassau Coliseum. Now, if they don't,
if they don't become the Brooklyn
fucking islanders than a, that
I don't need to go see him.
It's like if you change your foot, it's
still in New York. You know what I mean?
I don't need to fucking do that.
So I've seen 27 of the 30 fucking,
uh, I got three more to see in, um,
in hockey. So I'm going to try to
knock those out over the next year.
The Fan Slam is what I'm
calling it, you know, you know,
Serena's fucking the Serena slim. This
is just the fan slam. The fucking,
you know, you have no life.
You run the fucking road,
you don't want to kill
yourself in a comedy Condo,
so you start building it
around home games. Um,
I actually made a list and I don't
know if you're not a sports fan,
this is going to bore the shit out of you.
But these are all the fucking places
I've been to that now no longer exist.
Uh, the Boston Garden, Sullivan
Stadium, a Yankee Stadium, Shea Stadium,
Veterans Stadium, three rivers
stadium, soon to be no longer there.
Joe Louis Arena, the
RCA slash Hoosier dome.
I saw Peyton manning there. Uh,
I saw a game at original soldier field,
got a picture and then this fucking
asshole stole my goddamn camera. I was,
had a picture of me and
uh, when I went to, um, uh,
green bay packers, that game was
a, um, it was a preseason game.
They played the browns bred fabric
was still there. Verse he says,
I can't count that one because
it's preseason. But the reality is,
is you just wants me to book, you know,
book a Gig at like the skyline
cafe and go to a packers game,
which of course I will, I'll do. Alright.
Continuing on county stadium to
the target center, the Metrodome,
the Edward Jones Dome,
which is still there,
but the St Louis Rams don't play
there anymore. Texas stadium,
the Astrodome mcnichols Arena Mile
High Stadium, Sun Devil Stadium.
That still exists. But I saw the Arizona
cardinals versus the Patriots there.
Qualcomm stadium still exist, but the
fucking charges aren't there anymore. Uh,
I also saw that the, um,
San Diego Padres there and I went there
with and watch Mark McGuire take batting
practice the year. Uh,
he broke Roger Maris his record and
I saw him hit number 27 to 28 there,
uh, Addison field before
they redid it. Um, La,
the La sports arena that's still there,
but I saw, um, who did I see there?
I saw the clip was there.
I saw the clippers there and biggie smalls
was in the crowd and four days later
he was dead. Swear to
God. Uh, the La Forum.
Um,
I saw fucking a young Koby
Bryant and just left the,
uh, magic shack with
del Harris as a coach.
I want to say Dennis Rodman was on
that team. I went to candlestick park,
sat out in right field and saw a,
a early on head getting
bigger Barry bonds,
key arena for a Seattle Supersonics
game with a rookie year cad,
Kevin Duran, and then, uh, the kingdom.
I saw a young Ken Griffey Jr I
sat right out in center field,
a bleachers. And as far as I know,
oh, and you know what else? The, uh,
the Montreal forum,
I can't believe I forgot that I saw
the [inaudible] 1989 I went up there in
March and I saw I, uh,
Canadians versus the fucking Minnesota
North Stars with Patrick won that.
Okay.
I of course, rooted for the North
Stars and they of course lost. Um,
so whatever that that's the dumb bullshit
that I do when I'm out here on the
road. And now I can add the after
tonight, do Carolina and, uh,
I want to thank the comedy
zone for hooking us up,
um,
with some sort of Duke booster
that gave us those tickets.
And I was surprised the person came
to the game. I came to the game,
came to the show last night and left
without saying hello, which was,
it's like at least go to thank the guy.
So if he's listening or she's listening,
whatever the fuck it is, it got me
the tickets. Thank you so much. Uh,
and with that,
let's listen to me try to read out loud
as I practice for an awards show the
nominees for the best kiss in a fucking
we'll be about or not the close.
All right, Luke crate everybody. Give
me the loop. Speaking of Biggie smalls,
rest his soul.
Be The envy of your friends and get
your 100% exclusive crates@lukerate.com
slash bar and enter my code Burp B U R R
to save $3 off on any new subscription.
Crush that first sentence. Wait until
I tell you about February's crate.
It is very put together.
I fucked that one up.
Copy points mentioned at
least three times times spot.
Fuck does that mean on
a quest for epic gear,
housewares and collectibles Luke crate
has at the best surprises you know is
coming. We'll create offers
in epic. Focus texted me.
Oh, all right. Um, if you're
more of a fan testicle fashion,
I'm going to bomb it. This fucking thing.
Then try loot where monthly wearables and
accessories with Koch classics in your
favorite franchises. If
you want to get fancy,
get a bigger box with even bigger loop
with loop. Uh, do it with Lou crate.
DX. Want to geek out your pet tri.
Luke pets do we do? I don't
know who this is. Like
the shit is insane.
Do you just gonna buy all these crazy
shirts about fucking movies and put them
all over any living thing? If
you're a, you forgot a goldfish,
try a loot fish. Scoop
aware. All right. Get ready.
You get him a little
aqua man fucking outfit.
Get ready for the pop culture theme.
February's pop culture theme build.
We'll create as an awesome and exclusive
items from the most put together
franchises. This February experience.
Iconic items from mighty morphin. I
don't know what that is. Power ranges.
Batman, lego dimensions and
Tetris, including as always,
our monthly tee shirt and pin.
Go to Luke craig.com/bar and enter my
code burns say $3 off any new subscription
today. Um,
okay.
Holy Shit, this is perfect
for the award. Show.
The Black Tux looking great for a wedding
or or a special event has never been
easier with the black tux.com I'm fucking
doing this with high quality rental
suits. Then I got to measure myself,
don't I? I don't. Fuck do you do that?
You gotta Use Your Chin, right? Sure.
It can hold the drink down with the
high quality rental suits and Tuxedos
delivered to your doorstep.
The Black Tux is giving guys a
new way to rent and get this.
The black Tux offers free home.
Try on so you can see the fit and feel
the quality on your suit months before
your event. Well, I got days the
best part. It's complimentary.
Done online. No trips to the
Tux shop required. I right.
I when it does it twice, I
saw it the fucking first time.
The Black tux.com lets you create
your loot, your look, your Lou Craig,
your look or choose from tons of styles,
stylistic selected outfits
starting at just 95 bucks.
That's the kind of Tucks I'm looking for.
The suits have a modern fit and are
made from the, from fine Italian wool,
itchy, the highest quality
on the rail market.
And if you have any questions or issue,
their expert customer care team has
your back every step of the way.
After ordering your suit will
arrive 14 days before the event.
That's a full two weeks to try it
on and make sure everything fits.
If anything is less than perfect,
the black Tux will send you a free
replacement right away when your events.
So we just dropped the rental back in
the mail. Shipping is free both ways.
How easy is that to get started now?
Visit the black tux.com/born experience
a new way to rent that, the black
tux.com/berg all right,
I'm getting exhausted. Just
fucking reading blue apron.
Hey everybody, not all ingredients
are created equal man. Fresh,
high quality ingredients
make a real difference.
So it's important to know
where your food comes from.
Talk about how it feels to cook for
yourself. Oh my God. First of all,
what I love most about it is I can do it
in the nude. You know, it's my kitchen.
If I pulled the blinds, who gives a
shit? Right? You know, I put on an apron.
You know,
it's kind of like when you're completely
naked cooking with an apron on,
that's kind of like a, that's the
kitchen's version of chaps. Um,
each meal comes with a step by step,
easy to follow recipe card and pre portion
agreements and can be prepared in 40
minutes and left, uh,
less blue aprons freshness guarantee
promises that every ingredient in your
delivery arrives ready to
cook, although make it right.
Customize your recipes each week
based on your fucking preferences.
Blue Apron has several delivery options
so you can choose what fits your needs
and there's no weekly commitment.
So you only get deliveries when you want
them to check out this week's menu and
get the your first, uh,
your first three meals for free
with free shipping by going to blue
apron.com/pur you will love how good
it feels and tastes to create an
incredible, incredible home cooked
meals with blue apron. So don't wait.
The Blue Apron doc, that's
blue apron.com/bar blue apron.
A better way to cook. I
like those guys. You know,
they're giving you a healthy food and
they only make me say their website one
time. Alright, lastly,
but certainly not leastly
a distilled jeans,
uh, great jeans. Just don't
have to be complicated.
If you're not into crazy stitching
diamonds and embedded studs,
you're not alone. You know what's funny?
You know what it's about Com dad jeans
now guys who became dads and like the
last 10 years as those true religion ones
that add like that horseshoe stitching
on the fucking back.
I saw a couple of guys at the airport
wearing those and they had like kids and
shit in there, all faded. You know,
the dumb white stitching down the side.
I didn't even buy those things.
Those things from day one look like
some country singer Shit, right?
Alright. Distilled, pronounced
distilled, uh, offers luxury,
great denim at an affordable price change
that would normally cost you hundreds
to still has just starting 75 bucks. You
know what, they send me a pair of them.
They were really fucking Nice, uh, that
utilize the same fabrics in factories,
in wash houses as the best known brands
and designs while skipping the markups
and the middleman, the result,
pure on a delta rated denim with real
retail without the retail run around.
Just go to the.com spelled d s t l d
m.com. Uh, and see, um,
where middlemiss designs
meets maximum comfort.
They guarantee the fit those shipping
them for free and give you free items in
return until you find the perfect
pair. I'll give you free return. Sorry.
Distilled has been featured in Forbes
Times at tech crunch as well as on denim.
Glad celebrities and GQ and just still
is the only place in the u s you can get
this quality denim for this price.
You can find their amazing selections of
outerwear, leather jackets, tee shirts,
and more using the same principles of
high grade materials at low end costs.
Even celebrities are wearing just still.
Um,
I got a pair of the name, the
Jean Style and the fit is perfect.
They did give me a pair of jeans. I
don't know what style it is and uh, yeah,
they, they, they hugged
my junk pretty nicely.
Distilled still is your answer to
elevate style without elevated prices.
Just go to distill.com/for right
now and get 10% off your first pair.
That's d s t l
d.com/for for 10% off right
now. That the five letters,
d s t l d.com/ [inaudible].
All right, let's stop.
That's Delta, Sierra, tango,
Lima, Delta. All right,
let's get back to the tone for
the page here and finish this out.
Um, all right.
Is that been a half an hour? I have no
idea. I never know whenever I'm fucking
recording on just the garage
band thing here. So A,
we're going to go to the
game here tonight. Um,
I can't believe I'm going to see them
be this close to fucking coach k.
I know Duke's having a
tough time this year,
but coach k's back from
back surgery and um,
he did that thing where he, uh,
I guess every once in a while I
get so disgusted with his team.
He doesn't let them wear any Duke gear
and he won't let them in the locker room
until they start playing at a fucking
level that the university has used to see
you gotta Love That Old School
coaching that made me look up like 'em.
Okay.
You know,
I was looking up all this stuff on coach
k and I didn't realize that when he was
at army, he played for Bobby Knight.
I didn't know that he assisted with Bobby
Knight and all and there's all these
great fucking pictures.
He got to see the way Bobby Knight is
dressed in 1979 in Puerto Rico when he's
at the Pan Am games.
Of course he ended up getting arrested
because he allegedly slapped a cop or
something like that.
Yeah.
You want to talk about a guy that needs
to fucking meditate? Jesus Christ. Um,
yeah.
So anyways, uh,
I was watching all this stuff where's
coach sent me down this rabbit hole of
Bobby Knight stuff
and um, you know,
my favorite clip of all the Bobby
Knight ones was when somebody secretly
recorded them cause I feel like that
was the real Bobby night cause I thought
towards the end he kind of was,
was doing the Bobby Knight thing.
Like when he did that game face thing,
I think at that point he was just,
he started like hamming it
up when he didn't need to.
But like when you listen to that one
where he's talking about the Purdue game
coming up and that he has an eight
and 10 record, um, I swear to God,
I'm going to start listening to that
speech before I go to the gym because I
actually listened to that thing and he's
talking about how he had to go to some
function and he goes,
and I'm sitting there,
I'm tired of sit down with a
fucking eight and 10 record.
Everybody fucking look sick. Second
fucking time. Hello. Is it a fucking per,
do you guys get the fuck out there?
Send somebody if you
fucking lose to Purdue,
he put me in that fucking position. I
will fucking run you something until you,
I don't know, something about
puking or whatever. It's,
it's just such a great speech.
And then the end of it.
Yeah,
my natural reaction, I laughed and
just said, that's how it's done.
And a, I know we got a lot of criticism
for the stuff that he did, but um,
I think a lot of that criticism
came from people that, um,
are not athletic. We're never
in a locker room. And um,
yeah,
you know, they came from that whole, they,
they actually had bad
experiences in sports and
listening to Bobby Knight Yell I
think just brought all their sucking
in gym class memories back and um,
I dunno,
it's like there's this certain type of
person that is a fucking athlete and can
handle that and understands
what the fuck that is. And uh,
I think if they don't
have a problem with it,
all these people who don't play sports
should just shut the fuck up about it
cause you don't understand
what's going on. And um,
okay.
I mean, Jesus Christ,
Bobby Knight won almost a thousand fucking
games and all his former players for
the most part love them. And
um, and I always felt that kid,
that last fucking incident
that Bobby Knight had, um,
I thought that felt that kid was baiting
him cause Bobby Knight walked by and I
think the kid said, what's
up night? You don't say that.
That's totally disrespectful
and night just said that,
that fucking tempers zero
to fucking 9,000. Um,
but I remember when I heard that story,
like that kid was being a fucking cunt.
Um, but you can't do that shit anymore.
At least during his heyday, there
was no cell phone cameras, man.
He really would've gotten a lot of trouble
because they would have been fucking
video of that. And I
would've loved every second.
I would have loved every
second of watching him grab
some student by the fucking
throat who just, what's up
night guys walking around.
900 fucking wins. Some sophomore
comes by. That's come on.
Um, so anyways, yeah. So we're going
to be hitting that game tonight. Um,
if anybody knows, uh, oh, by the
way, I have to give a shout out man.
I went to a, um, this is my new thing
now when I'm on the road, you know,
cause I got my beautiful little daughter
up at home and I can't play drums as
much, you know, uh, Nia still lets me
rehearse and stuff like that, you know,
not rehearse, like practice and
shit when, uh, what I'm homeless
to pick the kids up. But, um,
I haven't been able to
go to a, a, you know,
the practice place that I go to out in
La as much as I would like. So I'm like,
why am I on the road out or
look up these rehearsal spaces?
So I looked up this place
when I was in Charlotte.
It's called the playground and
yeah. Um, I went down. Yeah man,
shout out to Eddie Z who runs it.
Totally fucking one of the
coolest dudes I've met.
A lot of these rehearsal
spaces are just absolute shit.
The drum kits are old. Everything's
fucked up. Everything sounds like shit.
I went into this place, this place
was like a fucking first-class place.
He stuck me in the best
room that they had a,
at a discount price cause they were doing
construction on some other rooms that
he didn't want them, you know, disturb
me or whatever while I was playing,
I played for like fucking
three hours. Well,
I paid for three hours long to get to
about, you know, two hours and 20 minutes.
And my body was like giving out on me
and I just had the best fucking time.
And you know what I love
when I went in there,
the snare gun was tuned too low and I
was able to tune it up to sound pretty
good.
And I used to not even remotely have
a game plan on how to tune up a snare.
And, um, I was really
psyched about that. Uh,
thanks. [inaudible]. Anyways, um,
this guy, Eddie z was
saying he, he actually, uh,
used to be a roadie for van Halen
and he was on the 1984 tour,
the last phone with
David Lee rough. And, uh,
then he did a couple with Sammy Hagar.
So he had all these fucking
really cool pictures,
just originals that he
took of like Sammy and, uh,
Eddie van Halen and Dave Lee Roth
was really fucking cool and, uh,
I had the best time and
like, that's gonna be on.
So what I'm gonna do when I'm on the road,
now that I'm on back building up the hour,
work in the comedy clubs like the
old days, uh, at such a great time.
Last night on stage a comedy zone.
Do Comedy Zone is one of the best fucking
comedy clubs out there. By the way,
if you can find the God
damn thing, you got to,
he walk in and there's like a
cafeteria, then a bar and there's,
there's a sign that says comedy
zone and nobody tells you.
You got to like ask like 20 people.
It's like you feel your
way through the dark.
Did finally go down those stairs to go
down there. But just the hallway, this,
the stage is set up. Um, it seems like
every seat in the house is a good seat.
Um, you know, for, I mean obviously
I've never sat in the crowd out there,
but uh, just had the best time
working the shit out. I did two shows,
both shows I was able to do a little
over an hour just pasting together new
ideas that I have and then
old bits that, you know,
never made it on to specials.
And I'm just thought out this is,
this is,
you wouldn't think so this is one of my
favorite times of doing stand up is just
letting everything else go and just
trying to figure out like what the new
shit's going to be. You know, I'm reading
newspapers, I'm bright and shit down.
Anything that I can
throw against the wall.
Last night I was on stage talking about
how fucking human beings are edible.
Like and everyone was like, what the fuck?
And that'd be something that I would
abandoned but I had no material and I just
kept going with it. And um,
yeah,
I dunno, it just takes
me back to my early days.
Um, I was stand up when
uh, because your skills,
like if you don't have the material,
it just complete your skills completely
diminished even though you have the
poise and the, the skill set because
you've been doing it that long,
but it's just completed.
Just imagine a band if they
had to like just work workshop,
some rifts in front of a fucking
crowd without like rehearse.
And that's the greatest thing about
the art of stand up comedy is that you
can't,
you can't go to a rehearsal space and
get this shit together and then fucking
like you have to second.
You like coming up with riffs and
front of the fucking crowd. Um,
and it's, uh, yeah, it's fucking
work. It's absolute work. But,
um, I don't know. I'm a fucking lunatic,
so I totally enjoy this part of it.
So anyways, that is the
podcast. Uh, once again,
thanks to whoever it is that
owns these two seats, um,
whoever that is, get in
touch with the comedy zone.
You have free tickets to any comedy
show that I ever do. Full life,
front row, whatever the fuck you want.
Forgiven given up these tickets. Um,
Jan, thank you enough. This is
going to be amazing. So I'm,
we're on our way up to Durham
and I was just out there,
so I know a couple of good
spots to eat at. So, uh,
we're going to have a good time.
All right, that's the podcast.
Go fuck yourselves. Have a great weekend.
Yukon and I will talk to you. Uh,
I'll talk to you on Monday. I'll let
you know about the game. All right.
Mm.
Uh,
[inaudible] uh
mm.
Hey,
what's up? This is Bill Barr and uh,
this is the Monday morning podcast.
I just did a 50 minute podcast.
I tried to save it and
didn't once again this week.
Talked for fucking hour
evidently to nobody. Um,
I'm going to have to buy some sort of
device so I can save them so I can try and
pull them back up. I don't
know what to tell you, but a,
I don't even know if this
one's going to record.
I don't know if I'm going too long.
I don't even know who the fuck I'm
supposed to call. Who the fuck do I call?
It's not like I called this number
on anybody you can talk to, picks up,
you know, typical of how we're living.
Do you know I was on the fucking
airplane flying out to Boston, right?
I'm on the airplane and for some reason
they always have the fucking intercoms
turned all the way up the 10. Right?
Hello is my God damn eardrums out. So
I say the lady, she walks by, I go,
is there any way you can turn the
thing down? She's like, Nah, sy die.
There's nothing we can do. You
mean there's nothing you could do?
You can go up there. He can
fucking turn it down. But it would,
they be installed an intercom system
on 10 with no fucking volume,
whatever. Fuck this technology shit.
I got to figure out,
somebody sent me an email about
something that I can record into.
I'm going to try to find that. I
guess I got to go out and buy it,
but I apologize. Um,
I'm gonna try to do one again
tomorrow or something like that. Uh,
oh Jesus. It was such a great podcast.
God dammit. All right. Whatever.
I'm gonna try tomorrow. So
all 14 of you hang in there.
I'm gonna do a podcast tomorrow.
All right. Take it easy.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
bill bar. I don't know what the
fuck is wrong with this g thing,
but I have figured out
how to save my podcast.
All attitude was press number two. For
some reason that wasn't hearing that,
you know, I dunno, she
was saying it or whatever.
The computer with the fucking
female voice has been saying it,
but I don't know what's
going on with this thing.
It seems anytime I record
something longer than a,
I don't know what a doesn't fucking go
through, but I know how to save them.
So all I'm saying is from here on out, um,
I won't lose any more podcasts,
but I'm going to do a podcast tomorrow
and I'm going to save the thing and
hopefully I can publish it. All right.
Thank you for your patience and God
bless the United States of America.
[inaudible]
Hey, what's going on? It's still, it
is the Monday morning port by podcast.
Somebody said, pull it.
The Monday morning podcast
will on Guy Island.
That's six 18 on a fucking Wednesday.
And I learned how to save these podcasts
and he'd go, this is the podcast.
This is it. I'm doing one
take. I don't give a fuck.
I've already done it three times and I'm
running a red light and I made it good
deal the deal. Oh Hey you
guys, you guys got cameras,
you got cameras where you're at. You know,
you run a red light and they
take your fucking picture.
And if for some reason you
have to pay the fucking ticket,
I got a way around it. I got
away around it that I've learned.
Somebody told me,
all you gotta do when you run the red
light is you gotta be in the center.
You know, if there's two
lanes, just be in the middle,
had half your car in one lane after
your car on the other lane and no,
it doesn't get your full license plate
or your full face and you throw it.
Granted, I haven't tried that yet,
but I heard you can do
that also is another way.
When I got my car out here
and last on delays, evidently,
evidently there's so many
fucking people out here that, uh,
that, you know, it takes, I swear to God,
it took like four weeks or six weeks
for me to get my license plate.
Something ridiculous.
So basically I drove around
for well over a month
with the, just the name of the
dealership where I bought my car at,
on both the front and the back.
And one day as luck would have it,
I was like going to the airport and I
ran a fucking red light and they took my
picture and I flipped out. I
was like, ah, fuck. You know,
that's me flipping out that, fuck.
See, I stick it acting. That's good.
Bill, could you raise the stakes you
want to? I really did. I was like,
you gotta be fucking kidding
me. This is fucking punk shit.
That's what I really did. But I
didn't want to yell like that. And um,
but basically all they had was the picture
of the dealership and my stupid face.
So I never got the tickets.
Why am I admitting to this?
Can they use this in a court
of law? Come and get me Shea.
So anyways, I'm driving down the street
and I don't have my laptop with me,
so I don't have your questions,
but God knows I read them enough times
that I can actually remember him once.
So here's the first question
somebody asked me, hey bill,
what kind of drum kit
that you have? And it, um,
well you have it a band and if so, do you
have any good band stories? All right.
I have a late seventies
Slingerland five ply,
the five ply shells and nobody wants,
everybody wants to three plus
shells from the late sixties,
early seventies to get that great tone.
Whatever the fuck they're talking about.
Well, fortunately I'm a comedian
so I don't give a fuck. I'll tech,
I'll take the extra two plies. And uh,
basically they're all bottom sizes.
14 by 24 bass drum. I add a 13,
I mean 30 had 14 and then
an 18 inch floor Floortime.
So years later I bought
the 16 inch floor Tom.
And recently I had another bass drum
cause I was listening to Primus and I was
like, I want to play like Tim Alexander,
even though I already had
a double pedal. I'm like,
I'm going to add another bass drum pedal
because that guy from slayer said it's
not the same unless you have
the fucking both of them.
So I went out and I bought another bass
drum and I should have realized the fact
that I suck with the double pedal,
that they added a second base drum.
All it was going to do was just take up
more room and it wouldn't make me any
better a drummer, but I did it.
So, uh, yeah, that's what I played.
I got an old snuggling kit and
have I ever been in a band? No,
I was never in a band. I
just had a fucking, I didn't,
the drums were at my house.
Everybody came over to jam man.
And we sucked. Which is why everybody,
whoever came over now has a real job.
Um, yeah, that's it. I
don't have any rock star.
I don't have any of you fucking fan
stories other than that we stunk the usual
shit. And the next question
somebody asked me was, uh,
what the fuck was the question
was some question about I guess late
at night they got these new economy
dentures, something like this.
That's what the person asked me.
Have you seen these economy dentures?
What the fuck is this? And, uh,
it's actually a really
interesting question because
I used to work in a dental
office and I know a little something
about dentures. Huh? We're going to meet,
it's peeling off another layer
of the onion as Madonna says.
You know, she actually had the
balls to say that one time.
She doesn't have any balls. God
knows. We've all seen her Twat, um,
that she actually had the nerve to say
that when she did yet another totally
planned out. You know, look, I
can dress like a whore this way.
Nice fucking parking
job. You fucking idiot.
Fuck. I swear to God, man.
People just, you know,
people cannot fucking drive out
here in la. They really can't.
Like a lot of people don't know that.
All they talk about is the traffic.
Who it good. It's good because so
fucking bed man. Well you know what,
when it clears up, the driving gets
it and people can actually drive the,
there are, I've established it
before. You know they fucking,
they suck at driving out here.
You're that homeless guy.
There's a homeless guy out here. I swear
to God he looks like George Clinton.
I'm from parliament. Anybody. So anyways,
you're asking me what
these economy dentures are.
I'm going to guess that they
are a one size fits all denture,
which really fucking bizarre.
And I bet I'm on the upper,
it has some sort of a form fitting
thing that will fit to your pallet.
It's horrific because when you get a
denture, you're actually supposed to,
you know this impressions,
you pour up a model,
you know if they took out some teeth,
they try to get the teeth to
look like your other teeth.
So you don't freak people out.
Like one day you look like a witch and
the next day you come walking in and look
like Guy Smiley. You know,
I used to work in a dental office. I
actually am certified to take x-rays.
I can take impressions. The
upper impression was the worst.
I'd always get some. I'm just going to
let you know that I'm a gagger. I gag.
Really?
Why don't you just brush your fucking
teeth so I don't have to worry about you
throwing up on the mud. The
fucking left sleeve of my, uh,
my what? What do you call
those? The doctor robe.
The doctor coat or whatever. Yeah.
I used to take the impressions
and people used to always gag
when you do the top. And if you
hang in there another eight seconds,
and then they always have done,
they always say, yeah, God,
I fucking hate the dentist. Really? Well,
why don't you brush your fucking
teeth? You idiot. You know?
I guess I do the same thing.
I ain't going to the gym,
but God knows I'm going to go order
a fucking pizza right now. Jesus.
I'm gonna move. So yeah,
that's what I would get.
So basically after you
took the impressions,
if you want to know the whole fucking
process and the person's going every five
seconds, if they don't puke on you,
you actually have a good impression.
Then you take it into the little lab and
then you take out the little Green Cup,
that rubber Green Cup,
that's all I remember.
Things could only be mixed in that.
I never took a chemistry class,
so I don't know why it couldn't
be just a plastic bowl,
but it was always those rubber things.
And then you'd mix it up
and then you'd pour it
into the fucking impression and then
you'd stick it on this little vibrating
thing, trying to get all
the bubbles out of it.
And it was nothing fucking worse if you
didn't get all the bubbles out of it.
And then I swear to God,
the bubble would always be right where
the person's tooth was and you'd fuck up
the whole impression. And then you'd
have to go in there and be like,
we gotta do it again. I'd
have to deal with that again.
So I would guess that what
they're doing is, is they, uh,
they're skipping that whole
step. I don't know what they do.
If you take a whole pack of juicy fruit
and you chew it up and then, you know,
form it to the top of your mouth and
then you mail that in and they make a
denture out of that. I have no
fucking idea. But that's really a,
that's really a scary thing. It's
a really scary thing, you know?
That's the kind of Shit
I wish people focused on.
Like everybody keeps talking about that
fucking broad where the eight kids,
can you believe it? I mean, that's
so irresponsible. Who gives a fuck?
People talking about all the
money she's going to cost us.
She's going to cost us what, a couple
million, you know, what about these?
Do you know the fucking bankers?
Three quarters of $1 trillion.
Nobody gives a fuck about that.
Some chicks squirts eight babies out
of her twat. It's going to cost us,
you know, one half of 1% compared
to what these fucking cons did,
who stole a trillion dollars and then
gave themselves $30 million bonuses.
Nobody gives a shit about that. You know,
some chicks squirts up fucking eight
babies and all of a sudden no one can stop
looking at it. You know
why? Because it has a face.
You know what she looks
like? That's the thing.
That's the genius of the bankers.
Nobody knows what a banker looks like.
I don't even know what the fuck my teller
looks like. I go to the Goddamn ATM
cause I worked nights.
Um, all right, what else?
What else could I do on this podcast?
This is going to be a short podcast.
I'm doing a podcast until I get home
and that's going to be it because I'm
exhausted with these fucking
podcast. All right? It's insane.
The amount of podcasts that I've done
this fucking week and to no avail.
You know,
it reminds me of listening to somebody
talking about who the fuck was it
recording with like a ray
Charles. You do like nine,
9,000 takes of Georgia on
my mind by the end of it,
you wanted to make them
deaf too. You know,
that's what I feel like right now
with these fucking podcasts. So, um,
I guess the last thing that I have to do
is I'm stuck in traffic waiting to make
my left hand turn to come
home to order a pizza, uh,
is I gonna announce the winner of the, uh,
the submissions for the
original a proc tologist.
I went to the proctologist
joke, I gotta admit, man,
they were all strong and
everybody seemed to like,
there's sort of an even amount of people
like in every one of them except for
one. So basically I think I'm gonna
pass out like a three or four DVDs.
You know, you know what? Everybody's
a winner, except for the one guy,
the one guy on meandered for 20 minutes
about having the chicks titty mashed in
the mammogram. He's the only one who
didn't get any votes. Everybody else.
The Guy with the potato salad
line got a lot of votes.
The dude who freak me out
get a bunch of votes and uh,
the dude who did the,
uh, had the great angle.
I thought this was the
most original angle of,
of the gay guy bragging that he's
dating approch cologists you know,
if he didn't listen to that
podcast, he was saying like,
it's kind of like if you know one of your,
one of your buddies started dating
a generalist, you know, and then,
then all your buddies would
be jealous. Like Jesus Christ.
I bet she can do some
freaky shit. You know,
you can bend her every which way
you're saying gay guys would do that.
I bet they'd get jealous if you started
dating a proctologist and they'd all be
sitting around going to Kai. I bet he
really knows his way around an ass.
Thank you. That was the hacky gay guy
voice. I don't know if you guys noticed,
but my chick voice is basically the hacky
gay guy voice. Just done it a whisper.
If you ever want to get that
impression down instead of going,
hi fellows. I just go,
hey, what's going on? This is
his relationship going exact site that
I am a complete fucking no talent.
And anyways, I'm in my garage
right now. So this podcast is over.
I know it was a quick one. I know.
It was a quick one. All right.
It's a little 12 minutes.
It's an ETP. All right.
Like guns and roses live. That's
what it's like. All right. Step.
I didn't drop the n word even though
there was a half black Obama guitarist in
my group.
How fucking drugged up with slash that
day where he fucking co-signed on that
one. Anyways, I want to thank
everybody who came out to the, uh,
my shows back in Boston. Uh,
the comedy connection at
the Wilbur Theater and out
in chicken p Massachusetts.
I had an, I had a great time coming back
there and a bunch of friends, family,
former babysitter from the 70
showed up. It was a, a was just,
it was an unbelievable weekend. And
uh, then I went out to chickopee,
Massachusetts. That show sold out as well.
And I was a bunch of drunks and
I made my way through it. And uh,
then I went back to my
fancy hotel in Boston.
I ordered a Philemon Yawn. The,
the made had left classical
music on the clock radio.
Trying to remember how this
went down. That's fine.
I walked into my a hotel room,
but you know the turn down service,
I don't know what that means.
They fold your sheets back
and they give you a mint.
And she left classical music
claim on my clock radio.
I ordered the a menu minion,
little mashed potatoes,
a glass of red wine. And
I sat there and ate it.
And it was one of the most
loneliest experiences I've
ever had in my life to the
point I actually had to call Robert Kelly
and tell him in the moment how lonely
I was. The stakes suck too. I actually,
it was such a bad space. I actually
didn't even consider putting a one on it.
I went straight to ketchup. That's how
bad it was. And I don't put anything on,
you shouldn't put anything on a
steak. It should just taste delicious.
And the thing was so fucking,
I ordered it medium rare and it was gray
all the way through and it was tough.
Like fucking shoe leather. That
Mozzarella. Um, anybody know the app?
What's that one from anybody?
I'll give you five seconds.
Tough like fucking shoe
leather. That Mozzarella,
I only know one other fucking person
who have a new that reference.
We have a brought it up and
he owns Gotham comedy club.
It was, uh, Eric Roberts and uh,
the of Greenwich village talk like
fucking shoe leather, that Mozzarella,
any the fucking steak stunk. And
I actually put ketchup on it.
I like it literally takes, it
tasted like fucking hamburger it.
No it didn't cause hamburger tastes
great, but you know what I mean?
Any chefs out there, you
never put ketchup. Okay,
let's do overrated or underrated.
You know, it's fucking overrated.
A one steak sauce. I
don't even get it. It's,
it's just, it sucks.
I am in a garage right now talking to
myself basically about fucking a one steak
sauce. Who gives a fuck?
I'm done with this podcast.
Next week you're going to get, you're
going to get a double album out of me.
All right? I promise you. But this
week you get in the EAP. All right.
Thank you to everybody who came out
to the Wilbur Theater in Boston,
Massachusetts and all you fucking meth
heads and drugs who came up to the hooky
Louth and chicken chickopee
Massachusetts. And uh, my next Gig,
my next upcoming Gig, I am going
to be at wise guys in Ogden, Utah.
I believe it's Saturday night,
the uh, February 21st. So,
uh, please come out to see me, man.
I've never done a club up that way.
I've only done colleges.
And why don't you come along and bring
your 18 fucking wives or whatever the
hell is you Mormons do out
there. And uh, you know,
I think a, you're a cool Mormon if
you're actually listening to this.
So you know, come out to the show and uh,
congratulations to the
Lakers in the Cavaliers, man.
You guys look like you're going to be
playing, you just playing a hundred game,
playing a fucking hungry
or game. But I have to,
I have to say this before I sign
off. I really think that, uh,
the reason why I can't stay on the fucking
NBA is unlike any other sports like
that sport, the officials
control the outcome of the game.
Like I've never seen. It's like,
it always like the Celtics Lakers was
a fucking great game and then down into
the end they just kept blowing
the whistle on both sides.
I'm not being a crybaby here. Lakers won
fair and square, but I'm just saying,
you know, sometimes they should just
put the fucking whistle away, you know,
just let them fucking play. And
they did that in the Cavaliers game.
It's like you got these two juggernauts
going head to fucking head and then this
little fat keeps blowing his whistle.
Now all the action stops and
then you know, you know, hey,
stop pushing him. That's ridiculous. Okay,
let's let them shoot
uncontested. It's the most,
it's the biggest fucking buzz kill to
the end of any game I've ever seen.
You know? And I love how they,
there's been a referee that was,
has been busted for having mob ties in
the fucking NBA and I'm supposed to act
like that's the only guy.
Like there was that was, yeah,
that was just one bad apple.
You know, I think, I don't know.
What do you guys think?
That's my question for you.
This week I'd have all
the four major sports.
Which referee do you
think if you bought them,
could influence the outcome of the,
the uh, the outcome of the game?
I'd have to go NBA cause it's so
easy to get a guy out of the game.
You just keep calling files in
football, you know, you want how many?
You just throw a guy out of the game,
you've got to wait til he, you know,
kick somebody in the balls
and spits in their face.
And I don't know what
will get me babbling.
And literally the light in my garage
went out. I got to get out of the car.
All right guys, that's it.
I'm going to save this podcast
so you're going to hear it.
What's, I don't know how
to fucking uploading.
It's been a brutal week.
Alright God, let's take it.
[inaudible] alright.
Fuck list bill. I wake up
at my girlfriend's house.
She leaves to work. I can't find
my socks. She says I have some.
She says I have some
just use mine in leaves.
I wake up later and I look for the
sock drawer. Top drawer. Right. Um,
and I find this list with about 20 to
30 names on it and my name is near the
bottom. Oh No. Some have
check marks on them,
et cetera.
I asked her about it and
while she's initially upset
it turns out to be her fuck
list. Wow. I don't even have a file.
I have a list in my head. She
actually made a fuck list.
Dude, you coined a phrase.
She said she made it after we got together
with some friends drunk one night.
She then admitted to being
somewhat of a whore. Her words,
not mine before we met,
but assures me that she
hasn't done anything since
she met me with anyone else.
I do believe her, but I
totally blew up on her.
And we haven't been
talking for a few days.
I also look a bit creepy as to why
I went through her door drawer.
It was in an envelope. Yeah.
You know what it is? Yeah.
You kind of look creepy, but
she would've done that to you.
You know women call it snooping when
we do it. It's fucking creepy. Anyways,
he goes, I need some help here on this
one too. I apologize. She already has.
Do I just say fuck it and forget
about it? What's Ne his take on it?
God dammit. You know what?
I'm going to have to ask
her. Take on that one.
I'm not going to have it on this
podcast. When I, when I go home,
I fly home tomorrow,
I'll try to have an
epilogue to this podcast,
um, or maybe tack it onto
to the following weeks.
That is a great question
because I don't trust this girl.
You know that when, when a
girl is that fucking free.
All right. And I know
girls are getting mad. Why?
Why can't we be as free as you?
I'll tell you why you can't because
you don't have to work at getting laid.
Okay, I can be sexually liberated.
I still have to go out to the bar,
man, I got to do a fucking
tap dance. You know,
like me getting laid.
It's like somebody on fucking a American
idol trying to get that ticket to
Vegas. You know? That's what it's
like as if for most guys anyways,
to get laid, even if you
get good at it, it's,
it's like fucking, you know.
Okay.
It's, it's, it's not hot, but you guys,
anytime you want to fuck you can fuck.
Look at that. Golden the came up
with a backup. I didn't know Zia.
I put my hand and I wasn't ready.
44 year old guy. I'm sitting there,
the bootleg can't even fucking talk. Um,
so that's what I would be worried about.
She said she's a bit of a whore. Like
I don't know if that's a good
thing or a bad thing or like a,
I don't know about that one. She
sat down and she made a list.
Jesus Cry 20 to 30 names. Now, this is
the thing, I don't know how old she is.
All right. 20, you know, for a girl,
20 to 30 names,
I don't think is even that bad.
The fact that she, well I dunno,
but we might be even worse because
they, they
are not honest about their numb. They do
the exact opposite of what we do. Guys.
We exaggerate our numbers. They
dial them fucking back like,
like women's, how many
guys are you been with?
Numbers is like when they put out how
many people are unemployed in this
country, you know, they try to
keep that number fucking down.
It's the same thing. Uh, a fuck list.
I mean, uh, I, I don't
know, I never get past that.
You sat around with your friends
are your friends all whores,
you know, and it's not like they just
sat there going, oh yeah, you know,
I've fucking, you know,
Bobby fell up fucking Dakota Tornado,
another fucking modern
name. Um, Range Rover,
whatever. Fucking people
call kids and boys now. Um,
and then, you know, there's
checks next to them of,
of like what she did with
them or how good the Dick was.
And uh, I,
I don't know if that's one of those things
that they all fucking do and you just
unfortunately peak behind the
curtain and you should let it go.
I have no experience with
something like that. Um, oh,
this would have been a great nia question.
I have to do this with her and
get into a fucking giant argument,
but then I run the risk of
possibly getting a fucking
preview of her fuck list,
which I don't want to know
about. I don't want to know.
I mean I gotta be honest with you.
I don't give a fuck at my age.
I don't give a clean good. Okay. What
do I think? You will fucking in a,
in a goddamn bubble. I hope your banged
enough guys and learned how to fuck.
I really do because I don't need some
fish in bed, you know, just laying there.
Haman fucked a lot of people.
Great. Isn't that great?
Do you want a pilot who hasn't flown
a lot of planes? You know there's,
there's give and take. Okay, you got
to, girl hasn't fucked a lot of guys at,
you know.
Okay.
She sucks a dick. Like
she's eating green beans.
That's the trade off yet.
Oh, a two. That sucks.
That really sucks for you.
Why were you going to wear one of
her socks to work though? You know,
with a little fucking Chris
Everett ball hanging off the back.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible].